hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk for
garyvaynerchuk.com
and uh i want to talk about storytelling
pr
you know branding stuff i love of course
um
i think there's way too many companies
it's starting to get obvious to me
there's a lot of companies that really
don't understand the importance
of telling your own story the amount of
brands and websites that i see being
reactionary to let's say a techcrunch
article or a mashable article or the
wall street journal
or ad age is baffling to me i don't
understand in this day and age
let me phrase that i do understand most
brands
corporate structured companies have pr
teams that are really playing by the old
rules of pr
pr is fundamentally changed there's so
much more authenticity in it
press releases are like doing smoke
signals
do you understand what i'm saying when
you've got ceos and personal brands and
brands within
companies the face of tech company maybe
it's a cfo maybe it's a
cto whatever it may be i don't
understand
why they think they need to have a
filtered canned response
to anything i don't understand when you
launch a new product or a feature
why they don't take a flip cam and just
say hey this is what we're doing i know
some of you might not like this
you know directing the story already
knowing what the stumbling blocks
i keep getting involved in these
consulting powwows
over the last couple of weeks where
people are like we're gonna launch this
we know what's gonna happen
a couple people are gonna like this
something like that but you know it's 95
percent better
this this five percent is going to
bother some of the original users
i don't understand when they tell me
it's so real
and they're coming from such a good
place and they don't want to hurt
anybody but they understand there might
be a seven percent
retention of anger over this little
subtle thing i don't understand
why they don't take a flip camera or a
video and just say that and when they
launch it when people sign onto their
site
you know that pops up and they talk
about it people are
waiting for people to cry about it and
they come out with a canned [ __ ]
response
it's just the whole thing is broken
communication is what keeps a marriage
healthy
a relationship healthy be the first to
communicate if you're a business or a
brand
and you'll always win wait for somebody
else to tell your story
and then you have to mold it is a losing
proposition
please rethink the way you handle pr in
your company
and here's the problem and i'm gonna get
a lot of flack for this because i have a
lot of friends in pr
a lot of them don't want you to rethink
it when you bring this up they're gonna
kind of dance
you know they don't want to change their
jobs because their jobs are changing
everybody who's in the pr business today
has a different job
than they did 24 months ago see you next
time on garyvaynerchuk.com